bonsoir bienvenue ça vous regarde en
direct ravi de vous retrouver au
sommaire ce soir que près par emmanuel
macron le président réélu joue avec les
nerfs de ses ministres pas de nouveau
gouvernement avant au moins une semaine
alors pourquoi est-ce si long qui pour
matignon quelle nouvelle équipe quelles
nouvelles méthodes le quinquennat qui
s'ouvre sera collectif a lâché le porte
parole gabriela fall mâcon 2 ce qui doit
changer c'est notre grand débat dans un
enfant avec nos invités notre grand
témoin est une grande figure de la
gauche française à 83 ans il a toujours
le goût de la politique au point de se
lancer dans une nouvelle aventure la
création d'un nouveau parti baptisé
refondations républicaine pour soutenir
emmanuel macron dans la majorité il va
même présenter des candidats aux
législatives jean pierre chevènement est
avec nous ce soir enfin nous retrouvons
nous affranchit pour leur parti pris ce
soir comment nos grands nous dira
pourquoi silien cohabitation et serait
explosive et plus d'économistes au
collège de france philippe aghion passe
au crible la stratégie économique d'
emmanuel macron voilà pour le menu astag
cvr n'oubliez pas on est là
[Musique]
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs s'il ya une chose que je
n'aime pas le président de la république
c'est agir sous la pression même si
selon ses mots le vote de dimanche
dernier l' oblige il prend son temps
avant de faire connaître sa nouvelle
équipe et son nouveau premier ministre
alors macron de à quoi peut-on
s'attendre
on en parle avec mes quatre invités ce
soir dominique rousseau bonsoir joueurs
et merci d'être là vous êtes
constitutionnaliste professeur a pas
rien jusqu'à quand emmanuel macron
peut-il garder jean castex c'est l'une
des questions comble à vous poser ce
soir sitters pour la démocratie continue
chez odile jacob c'est votre dernière
ouvrage bonsoir jean daniel lévy ravi de
vous retrouver sur ce plateau directeur
délégué harris interactive france
emmanuel macron peut-il perdre les
législatives
vous nous direz ce que révèlent les
études d'opinion pas facile d'ailleurs
de mesurer des choses pour les
législatives bonsoir corinne lake fois
bienvenue vous êtes l'une des
observatrices les plus fines de ce qu'on
appelle la macro ni journaliste à
l'opinion vous venez de publier la nuit
tombe deux fois chez fayard avec eric
mandonnet et puis ce papier changer ou
ne pas changer c'est le titre d'un long
article truffé d'infos dans l'opinion
que vous avez publié en début de semaine
sur le défi du second mandat d' emmanuel
macron on en parlera je précise que
mathilde siro nous attend dans un
instant elle va nous rejoindre mathieu
siro qui suit pour le point le président
de la république elle a aussi plein
d'infos coulisses sur les projets du
président réélu mais d'abord pour nous
planter le décor comme chaque soir
j'accueille mon complice stéphane
blakowski quels sont les choix de macron
2 on l'accueille tout de suite
[Musique]
bonsoir stéphane on sort myriam bonsoir
à toutes et à tous si j'ai bien compris
ce soir et ben si j'ai bien compris ce
midi le président a mis un énorme
cadrage débordement à toute la presse
française qui donc s'est retrouvé bas
sur le cubain comme souvent dans ces cas
là bah oui c'est ça principe du cadrage
débordement oui qu'est ce que c'est ça
le cadrage à mais bordel en terme de
rugby qu'à page d'album d'abord dans ces
mers d'éditer l'adversaire donc
j'explique vous faites semblant de
partir à gauche et hop vous passez à
droite avouez que c'est quand même assez
proche du style macro et on passe d'un
côté à l'hôtel un démonstration pour
mieux comprendre avec aurélien rougerie
champion de france de rugby avec
clermont on regarde donc quand tu prends
volontiers un peu le ballon ici c'est
d'amener son défenseur ici pas de
repartir là bas n'est ce pas compliqué
hop un coup à droite un coup à gauche
risque est arrivé aux journalistes ce
midi ils étaient là ils étaient comme le
pack prêt
nacre ont pour le poser des questions
sur nouveau gouvernement le nouveau
premier ministre et hop cadrage
débordement gabriel est l ordi mais les
gars mais le quinquennat c'est jusqu'à
14 mai si ça s'ouvre la semaine
prochaine ça sera exactement le même
gouvernement comme quoi mâcon voyez il
est nouveau c'est le nouveau mac seront
normalement ils restent maîtres des
horloges comme un mondial c'est vrai
qu'on s'attendait à ce que ce serait le
dernier conseil des ministres ajoute moi
le premier matin je lisais parisien
comme d'habitude qu'est ce que je vois
ministre en sursis vous savez ce que
c'est les journalistes politiques sont
très proches des personnels politiques
dont attendrissent facilement oh là là
ces pauvres ministres qui vont se faire
bien y avait même la liste blanc caire
va se faire virer schiappa va se faire
virer parce qu'elle parle trop bachelot
va se faire virer parce qu'elle ne parle
pas assez oui il ya plein de motif sauf
que bachelot elle a l'habitude elle
s'est déjà fait bien d'un gouvernement
donc elle peut expliquer ce que ça fait
a blank et réagir par une écoute faut
être lucide c'est à dire que quand on
quitte une fonction ministérielle
il ya toujours un petit moment de
passage à vide et vous prévenir sa
famille et ses amis en disant écoutez je
peut-être pour être de très bonne humeur
pendant quinze jours 1 jean michel
blanquer requête cessiez je viens donc
s'il est un peu grasse il faut
comprendre pourquoi et puis un autre
conseil ne veux pas chercher à apitoyer
les français parce que un ministre qui
se serviraient sa sainteté pleurer
personne
moments douloureux il ya des moments
douloureux pour les français il ya des
moments doux pour eux pour pour des gens
qui souffrent véritablement mais alors
vraiment la pleurnicherie et comme pas
c'est indécent
d'avoir nommé emmanuel macron il a pas
de choix n'ont d'ailleurs comme il a
nommé deux premiers ministres de droite
pour son premier quinquennat on l'a
demandé hier quand il était à cergy
pourquoi pas nommer un ministre de
gauche histoire de changer un peu
moi qui prends au dépassement la couleur
politique ne dit pas tout
je mènerai quelqu'un qui est attachée à
la question sociale et à la question
environnementale à la question productif
bon ça nous donne quoi un petit portrait
robot non cette quelques signes
vous vient de vous planter un énorme
cadrage-débordement matin là ils vont
faire une feinte et vous replonger de
nouveau mais non c'est une fin ça veut
rien dire ça un premier mini social
productif et puis quoi écologie regardez
en 2019 il a donné une interview à la
télévision suisse pour ce maire on n'a
pas les moyens de se payer l'extrait
c'est beaucoup trop cher elle est ce
qu'il disait en 2019 à son triptyque
s'est elle-même police d'être productif
écologique et sociale donc voyez non
seulement il reste seul maître des
horloges mais en plus il n'a absolument
pas changé ligne on se demande où est
nouveau macro n'entendent pas il ya un
nom qui revient avec insistance c'est
quand même celui de elisabeth borno la
pauvre jonathan dubas premier ministre
c'est qu'on ne sait pas une sinécure ces
paiements boon qui a dit que ce serait
certainement une femme puis quoi en tout
cas c'était lorsque du président puis
pascal canfin qui était un peu près sans
tics scanne le plus écolo de la macro ni
a dit non pour en remettre une couche
encore et on qu'il a insisté
je pense que la priorité est d'avoir une
première ministre si on regarde
l'histoire ça fait 30 ans qu'on n'a pas
eu de femme à matignon 30 ans je veux
mettre fin à cette anomalie donc
forcément il est belle bande l coche les
trois cases en ton pardon elle a un côté
social puisqu'il faut l'être elle était
proche du ps bon c'est toujours ça elle
a un côté productif elle a été pdg de la
ratp c'est quand même p dg et puis
qu'est-ce qu'il faut encore être
écologique là elle a été ministre de
l'écologie de la trois casques et le
coche et même 2 15 supplémentaires
quelques roches la 4e case c'est que
c'est une femme on sait que ça compte et
la cinquième case c'est qu'elle ne
risque pas de faire de l'ombre à
maquereau et ça je pense que c'est bien
que je casse aussi pour le futur prof
est peut-être la plus importante c'est
ça que vous nous dit c'est à 15 qui
dément vous avez des spécialistes pour
en parler merci pour cette chronique
épices et comme tous les soirs merci
stéphane on va revenir évidemment sur le
nom d'elisabeth bornes dans un instant
puisque c'est elle qui apparemment tient
la corde mais on va d'abord faire un
point de méthodes avec vous dominique
rousseau le second demande à des manuels
macron commence officiellement le 13 mai
à minuit absolument est ce que ça veut
dire que jusque là jean castex pour
rester premier ministre jusque là jean
castex je peux effectivement rester
premier ministre le nouveau mac rond
entre guillemets prendra ses fonctions
le 14 mai 20h à temps et donc c'est à ce
moment là que jean castex pourra
présenter sa démission auprès au nouveau
président des pumas corps mais alors ça
veut dire que donc il reste 2 mercredi
oui le 4 et le suivant ça veut dire
qu'il y aura il peut y avoir deux
conseils des ministres avant et on peut
présenter des textes de loi dans le
cadre de ces conseils des ministres on
sait que il a promis de faire très vite
des choses sur le pouvoir d'achat on
peut présenter des textes de loi à
l'assemblée nationale est en fonctions
jusqu'au 12 jusqu'au 12 juin qui est le
premier le jour du premier tour des
élections législatives donc jusqu'au 12
juin l'assemblée nationale est là et les
totalement habilité à prendre
sièges et avec les sortants enfin c'est
jose ils sont absolument pas seulement 4
ans à des présentations de texte en
conseil des ministres il le conseil des
ministres est l'état continue l'état
continue tel qu'il est constitué
jusqu'au 13 mai au soir donc le
gouvernement est en place le président
de république est en place l'ancien
souvenirs et l'assemblée nationale est
toujours là elle sera là jusqu'au 12
vous croyez que il pourrait convoquer
comme ça soit un texte de loi ça ne
serait jamais vu dans la 5e c sauf si ya
urgence non je ne les ai jamais vus dans
la 5ème bien entendu mais le président
la république a dit qu'il y avait
urgence dans l'ensemble d'achat
notamment avec un projet de loi de
finances rectificative exactes sur
l'indexation au moins engager un projet
doit le soumettre à l'assemblée
nationale tout en sachant que évidemment
bien il ya un fort risque que je ne
puisse pas aller jusqu'au bout corinne
lhaïk alors pas de nouveau gouvernement
avant au moins une semaine pas surprise
que ça prenne plus de temps c'est un
classique c'est oui j'ai il ya quand
même deux précédents historiques
rappelez vous à quel point le
remplacement de deux de gérard collomb
par christophe castaner a été long ça a
été 15 jours pendant lesquels edouard
philippe assurait l'intérim de ministre
de l'intérieur c'est un vrai casse tête
à chaque fois et c'est vrai que l'idée
de présenter un le paquet on appelle ça
le paquet pouvoir d'achat assez
rapidement donc avant les élections
légistatives c'est à dire le sucre et le
miel avant le vinaigre et avant une
échéance électorale
c'est peut-être pas complètement
malhabile de la part de macron s'il y
songe mais il est clair que concernant
le changement de premier ministre
mc on va prendre son temps je ne vais là
il est en train quad de faire un petit
peu mariné et ses ministres et des
journalistes proches disent que et des
indices ou
ses proches de jeunes n'a pas encore
complètement arrêté son choix moi je
raisonne par en faisant le parallèle
avec ce qui s'est passé pour jean castex
castex a été nommé monsieur confinement
début avril 2020 et il est aussitôt dit
à certains de ses proches de le
surveiller de près parce qu'il songeait
déjà en faire son premier ministre en
juillet c'est à dire trois mois plus
tard donc il a peut-être quelqu'un dans
son viseur que nous ne connaissons pas
donc que nous ne connaissons pas le nom
le fait que tous les noms les noms qui
sortent aujourd'hui sont peut-être
forcément ceux qui ne seront pas retenus
c'est la loi du genre et peut-être qu'il
va nous sortir ce nouveau lapin castex
de son chapeau dans quelques donc dans
quelques jours en tout cas le long assez
difficile je pense de faire des
pronostiques à partir des noms qui c'est
moi ou bien sûr on est très prudent et
c'est sûr et ses pairs sur le name
dropping mais je sais que vous êtes bien
informé mathilde 0 bonsoir et bienvenue
sur ce blog la journaliste politique au
point d'abord on a l'impression qu'il a
du mal à séparé de l'anc est ex c'est
vrai ou pas jean castex il ay là il a
fait ses preuves à matignon c'est un
homme de confiance pour le président qui
ne lui fait pas donc qui malgré tout
même s'il n'était pas forcément issus de
cette majorité puisqu'il vient des
républicains a plutôt trouvé sa place
qui fait voilà qui vraiment être à la
manoeuvre et et travaille beaucoup il a
fait plus de 340 déplacement je crois
depuis qu'il a été nommé en juillet 2020
fond s'il n'y avait pas une nouvelle
impulsion à donner notamment après ce
que dira les urnes aux législatives
grande plus je pense qu'il est
confortable pour emmanuel macron ça
c'est certain malgré tout et emmanuel
macron a été réélu sept voilà une
nouvelle page qui s'ouvre pour lui
valent des politiques incana une
nouvelle donne politique il a promis que
ce quinquennat n'aurait pas grand chose
à voir a priori avec le premier donc ça
veut dire aussi un changement de tête et
ce choix de matignon est d'autant plus
compliqué parce que ça va être le
premier signal politique qui leur a
envoyé après son élection donc le profil
la coloration politique de cette
personne cette nouvelle méthode tout ça
va être regardé de très près et on l'a
dit et des élections législatives qui
l'idée de choisir entre un profil plutôt
techno elisabeth bordj à vous demandez
vous prononcer sur ce nom là mais ou
plutôt politique on parle de richard
ferrand de françois bayrou est ce que
c'est une voie là une tension un choix
qui s'offrent à lui ou pas oui c'est
l'équation qui qu'il a devant lui
certains le pousse dans son entourage
justement à incarner cette nouvelle
méthode avec un premier ministre plus
fort politiquement donc ça plaide plutôt
pour ses grognards françois bayrou
richard ferrand mais on a vu qu emmanuel
macron avait pris goût à fonctionner en
binôme avec un profil plutôt techno
plutôt experts et donc donc ça plaide
plutôt pour un nouveau castex mais
encore une fois c'est dans la tête du
président il ya peu tout ce qui qui a le
culte du secret et il a fait son choix
et c'est toute la question jean daniel
lévy et évidemment il ya une nouvelle
donne politique et des attentes on va en
parler on va parler de la feuille de
route de ce nouveau quinquennat mais sur
le premier ministre alors il doit
répondre à la question sociale et
environnementale
est-ce que ça ça correspond à une
orientation en phase avec les français
complètement complètement et avec des
effets politiques et qui peut être assez
rapide l'arrivée de edouard philippe il
y à cela 5 ans sur le perron de matignon
était un peu une surprise pour les
français et il est arrivé en disant
trois mots je suis de droite et le fait
qu'il le dise de manière aussi massive
ça une répercussion immédiate sur le
comportement des électeurs dans le cadre
des élections législatives qui ont suivi
très rapidement on était face à des
électeurs qui étaient plutôt proche des
républicains qui a vu rencontrer des
difficultés à voter pour françois fillon
pour tout un tas de raisons qui sont dit
on prendra notre revanche aux élections
du 7 6 au 10 ans on n'avait pas compris
en fait on a gagné et en fait on a non
seulement edouard philippe qui assume
clairement le fait d'être de droite mais
il ya également bruno le maire gérald
darmanin qui incarne une ossature qui
clairement envoyé jeudi à l'ats en 2022
pour s'assurer une confortable majorité
politiquement il doit dire le premier
ministre nouveau je suis de gauche pas
forcément je suis de gauche en tout cas
je suis attentif aux préoccupations
économiques sociales et
environnementales qui sont assez trans
partisan 1 mais en tout cas on voit bien
que ce sont des sujets absolument
centraux à l'heure actuelle qui ont
contribué l'élection d' emmanuel macron
dans le cadre du deuxième tour de
l'élection présidentielle et qui
permettent de nourrir en tout cas de
réduire son interrogation que peuvent
avoir nos compatriotes alors pour
gouverner on va attendre évidemment donc
au moins une semaine si je comprends
bien de savoir qui pour matignon et
quelle nouvelle équipe il va bien
falloir avoir une une majorité on entend
beaucoup de choses du côté des enquêtes
d'opinion il faut prendre voilà beaucoup
de précautions sur des différentes
projections à ce stade du premier tour
sur sur les législatives certains comme
jean luc mélenchon rêve d'une
cohabitation
pour l'heure ça ne s'est jamais produit
pour un président élu ou réélu comme
nous le rappellent les os
dans l'histoire de la vème république
une date à marquer un tournant pour les
élections législatives
le 24 septembre 2000 les français votent
pour l'abandon du septennat présidentiel
remplacé par le quinquennat
il s'agit de rendre plus probable
la coïncidence de deux majorités la
majorité présidentielle et la majorité
législative c'est-à-dire diminuer le
risque de cohabitation c'est à dire
sortir de la paralysie de nos
institutions deux ans plus tard le
nouveau calendrier électoral place la
présidentielle avant les législatives et
les conséquences politiques sont
immédiates c'est devenu la règle les
élections législatives donnent une
majorité au président élu une élection
de confirmation
2002 jacques chirac rpr vient d'être élu
dans la foulée l'hémicycle eux penchent
majoritairement à droite
2007 je ne vous trahirai pas nicolas
sarkozy arrive au pouvoir c'est une
victoire pour la majorité présidentielle
l'ump obtient à nouveau la majorité des
sièges en 2012 l'heure est à
l'alternance avec la victoire du
socialiste françois hollande mais c'est
une nette très nette victoire de la
gauche portés par cet élan l'assemblée
bascule et se teintant rose
il ya cinq ans en 2017 jamais élue est
porté par un parti encore embryonnaire
emmanuel macron réussi l'exploit de
conquérir l'elysée
national avec la république en marche
modem avec 355 ciel inattendue les
législatives accorde qu'une majorité de
sièges à ce parti qui à tout juste plus
d'un an un effet lune de miel toujours
au bénéfice du parti présidentiel du
fait de la proximité temporelle entre
les deux élections à cela il faut
ajouter le mode de scrutin majoritaire
pour les législatives un système qui
confère au parti en tête une large
avance alors le seul président réélu
depuis 2002 peut-il faire perdurer cette
règle réponse le 19 juin prochain
jean daniel lévy quand on regarde les
sondages on s'étonne beaucoup disent par
exemple et la boue même ipsos j'imagine
que chez vous aussi six français sur dix
votre une majorité de députés opposés à
emmanuel macron alors qu'est ce que ça
veut dire ça voudra dire qu'ils
attendent une cohabitation est ce que
c'est inquiétant pour emmanuel macron où
c'est beaucoup plus compliqué que ça
dans le cadre de cette enquête qu'on a
réalisé chez harris interactive pour
pour charge par exemple on voit bien
qu'on a globalement ce même type de
schéma 20% la question qui a trop dans
cette manière montgiscard la semaine
type de schéma est ce que c'est nouveau
pas du tout est ce que on a le
globalement cette appréciation de la
part des électeurs après chaque élection
présidentielle oui systématiquement
quand on regarde aujourd'hui la moyenne
on réalise les électeurs par rapport à
maintenant qu'ils pouvaient réagir en
2010 est il exactement ce même type ça
veut dire que c'est sûr mais il n'y a
pas un seul bloc qui voudraient
mélenchon premier ministre par exemple
surtout pas ça qu'on s'est bien en fait
que on peut être d'accord c'est sûr
qu'on est en désaccord mais pas tout à
fait aller les uns ou les autres être
dans la même direction donc le front des
oppositions ne se réunit pas vers un
seul candidat et aujourd'hui foule à
vous le dis il faut être extrêmement
prudent à l'égard des propositions qu'on
peut avoir mais à travers les premiers
travaux qu'on a pu être amené à réaliser
on voit bien que tous se dirigent si la
campagne se déroule sans accroc pour une
majorité qu'ils soient à nouveau accordé
au président l'appliquent emmanuel
macron c'est le fait non seulement en
fait d'un bloc majoritaire qui a
tendance à s'étendre c'est le fait d'un
mode de scrutin mais c'est également
surtout le fait de démobilisation et
historiquement les électeurs qui ont
voté pour un candidat qui n'a pas gagné
la présidentielle ont tendance à se
démobiliser certains avantages qu aux
électeurs mélenchon le pen en 2017 et ça
semble être encore le cas aujourd'hui
dominique rousseau il faut il faut
rappeler qu'il ya toujours un effet
amplificateur aussi liées au mode de
scrutin en 2017 la république hors
marché le modem obtiennent trois cents
soit 50 députés avec seulement 30% des
suffrages là on est dans le même cas de
figure où c'est plus compliqué c'est
différent
alors c est différent et compliqué je
partage l'analyse qui vient d'être faite
avec une nuance c'est que jusqu'à
présent les élections avaient lieu
trois semaines après l'élection
présidentielle
là elles ont lieu deux douars et les
élections présidentielles donc comme on
dit peut se passer beaucoup de choses la
question de la nomination du premier
ministre qui peut s'il nomme un premier
ministre correspond parfaitement à ce
qu'il a dit écolo famé et social et s'il
dépose un projet de loi pour le pouvoir
d'achat et c'est bon là ça va couper
l'herbe sous le pied et de le pen et de
et de mélenchon donc il ya quand même
deux mois qui permettent aux partis
d'opposition de ceux de se mobiliser
donc c'est la différence avec les les
fois précédentes où effectivement chaque
fois le président de la république a eu
une majorité quasiment automatique après
son nom qu'on est un peu dans quelque
chose d'inédit c'est ce qu'on est dans
quelque chose d'inédit à cause du délai
de deux mois où il peut se passer un
certain nombre d'événements qui vont
bousculer
cette hypothèse de la cohabitation à
grand renfort de cette affiche choc de
jean luc mélenchon premier ministre
élisez moi premier ministre lance-t-il
aux français c'est pas gardé par tous
ses militants dans dans les rues de
france s'inquiète ou pas en macro ni
emmanuel macron est persuadé depuis le
début qu'il aura une majorité il l'était
déjà en 2017 en 2017 ils étaient tous
nouveaux arrivés dans le paysage et tout
le monde lui prédisait oui d'accord il
peut être élu président de la république
mais il n'a pas de député il n'a pas de
réseau il est absolument impossible
qu'il ait une majorité il l'a eu l
écrasante comme vous l'avez montré tout
à l'heure et là il est à nouveau
persuadé qu'il va avoir une majorité au
nom des lois que vous venez de rappeler
donc a pas d'inquiétude de d'avoir une
cohabitation avec mélenchon on voit bien
que mélenchon qui fait de la politique
et on voit bien surtout que cette
élection a quelque chose d'assez
particulier c'est que les vaincus
transforment leur échec en victoire que
ce soit marine le pen ou jean luc
mélenchon mais l'arithmétique électorale
et politique doivent normalement amené
macron avoir une majorité avec ce bémol
il faut se rappeler le précédent de 2007
où jean louis borloo nommé ministre de
l'économie avait fait une petite bêtise
tva
dans un piège tendu par laurent fabius
il avait parlé de la tva sociale et la
future majorité et la majorité m avait
perdu quand même 80 sièges semblait
soulagé le fond bruno leleu 49 fois le
maire qui dit 49,3 bon je pense il s'est
laissé piéger
d'où la nécessité effectivement
d'occuper le terrain avec des mesures
plutôt agréable jean pouvoir d'achat
plutôt que de laisser
la porte ouverte à voir d'ailleurs
quelle est la feuille de route la plus
prioritaire ski quels sont les chantiers
qui attendent le président et cette
nouvelle équipe dans dans un instant
matile siro il ya aussi des députés qui
sont sur le grill en ce moment où on
parlait des ministres avec que là les
nerfs sont à vifs mais il ya des députés
on a vu un papier dans le parisien qui
nous explique que tout est validé les
investitures par le président de la
république ça c'est un classique et puis
en gros il ya des gars des notes c'est
ça un tableau rouge vert orange avec
passable pas papa fiable faible part pas
faim voilà force ça se passe comme ça
c'est un peu comme à l'époque de
françois mitterrand emmanuel macron veut
tout contrôler et veut tout valider lui
même un président presque omniscient en
fait il a effectivement un tableau très
précis des circonscriptions avec d'un
côté les députés sortants ceux qui
veulent repartir au combat et ceux qui
ne veulent pas parmi ceux qui veulent
repartir au combat eh ben il ya ceux qui
ne sont pas sûrs de pouvoir le faire
exactement il ya ceux qui vont
effectivement
obtenir l'investiture officielle et
d'autres qui ne l'ont pas et je pense
qu'ils ne sont pas au courant
aujourd'hui ceux qui n'auront pas
l'investiture qu'ils ne l'auront pas ce
qui peut poser quand même des problèmes
parce que certains voudraient qu'il soit
en campagne voilà un vote et certains
commencent à ouvrir leur leurs comptes
de campagne a lancé les militants etc à
s'organiser et on va leur dire en fait
non ça ne sera pas toi ce sera un autre
candidat un ministre ou que sais-je
sachant que le calendrier fait
maintenant 1
dans une période où les tensions
risquent de s'exacerber
et pas qu'à l'intérieur d'ailleurs des
sortants parce qu'on sait qu'il ya
énormément de partie vous allez en
parler avec monsieur chevènement des
nouvelles boutiques pro macron qui se
monte et ce malgré l attique dans la
mode comme tda dans la future
législation oui je pense que vous avez
raison de rappeler que le prêt à la
république essaie de contrôler les
futurs des députés et surtout pour
emmanuel macron qui a le souvenir de
françois hollande parce que c'est pas
françois hollande qui avait désigné qui
avait donné les investitures c'est
martine aubry qui pensaient qu'elle est
à gagner la primaire est donc françois
hollande s'est retrouvé avec une
majorité mais une majorité qui n'avaient
pas construite est bon et mathieu et
elle a donc pour lui c'est important de
construire sa majorité avec des députés
qui lui soient fidèles là où il ya une
difficulté
à un direct et non voulue évidemment
c'est la question du financement des
partis politiques
ce qui va rendre très difficile je pense
les
regroupements où les alliances par
exemple pour pour mélenchon avec le
parti socialiste et les écologistes
parce que pour avoir un financement il
faut présenter il faut qu' il faut
présenter des candidats je crois dans 50
% des résidents au moins 1% et ça dépend
chef du groupe parlementaire du nombre
de députés bon donc il ya des enjeux
aussi à ce qu'il y ait ce que chaque
partie à chacun pour soi pour des
raisons simplement financière alors on
va essayer de voir si pour l'avenir on
peut assister un changement de méthode à
vous entendre pour l'instant on n'y est
pas c'est encore emmanuel macron qui
contrôle les investitures qui prend son
temps mais cette majorité est elle si
elle a lieu si elle est élue elle va
avoir beaucoup de travail quels sont les
grands chantiers qui attendent le
président élu et peut-on s'attendre à un
changement de méthode aussi pour les
faire aboutir tour d'horizon avec
clément méric
ce n'est pas un chantier en soi mais
c'est le principal sujet de
préoccupation des français pour emmanuel
macron le pouvoir d'achat est aussi un
enjeu politique
il lui permet de lancer son quinquennat
sur une ligne plus sociale à l'opposé de
la suppression de l' isf en 2017 il
compte donc aller très vite sur ce sujet
je veux permettre aux travailleurs de
pouvoir que c'est une prime de pouvoir
d'achat
toutes les mesures de pouvoir d'achat
seront dans un projet de loi présenté au
parlement dès le mois de juillet
emmanuel macron a promis une nouvelle
méthode pour ce second quinquennat la
réforme des retraites servira de test il
faudra de manière concertée bien sûr de
manière progressive et visible passé
l'âge de notre retraite cinq ans
la concertation avec les partenaires
sociaux devraient être lancés rapidement
la réforme elle ne sera pas débattue
avant l'automne voire le mois de janvier
pas de calendrier précis pour ce
chantier mais là aussi le maître mot est
la concertation une commission
transpartisane va être mise en place
elle devrait plancher entre autres sur
la proportionnelle aux législatives
le rétablissement du septennat et
l'éventuelle mise en place d'élections
de mi-mandat
[Musique]
emmanuel macron confiera cette
planification écologique au premier
ministre qui devrait s'appuyer sur deux
ministres là en charge du volet énergie
l'autre en charge de la transition
écologique dans les transports les
logements ou l'alimentation
quatre autres chantiers seront lancés
cette année l'école la santé la justice
et le grand âge
corinne lake vous connaissez bien au
fond la personnalité la manière de
fonctionner du président de la
république vous avez écrit cet article
changer ou ne pas changer on nous
explique que macron de ce sera avant
tout une nouvelle méthode on le voit sur
les retraites sur les institutions aussi
est-ce qu'on peut le croire je pense que
au moment où il le dit promet une
nouvelle méthode il est sincère mais les
événements ont prouvé que macro ne
change que quand il est obligé de
changer il l'a fait avec les gilet jaune
il a fait avec la crise de lakovic toute
question toute la question c'est de
savoir quelle est l'analyse qu'il fait
de la situation actuelle s'il estime que
la crise démocratique que nous
traversons la colère des français qu'il
n'a pas réussi à apaiser pendant son
quinquennat le fait que l'extrême droite
a progressé d'un scrutin à l'autre
peuvent l'amener à se dire il ya
vraiment le feu et il fait changer mais
qu'est ce qu'ils en disent autour des
présidents d'agglo stx et qu'il ya
urgence ils disent aujourd'hui qu'ils
vont le faire mais le vrai sujet c'est
que il est pris dans un étau c'est que
d'un côté il veut changer de méthode
parce qu'il sait que c'est pour lui le
moyen de faire passer ses réformes et en
même temps il est obligé d'aller vite il
veut vraiment transformer la france
parce que sinon son premier quinquennat
ne leur a pas permis de le faire donc il
a besoin d'un deuxième mandat pour le
faire et donc il va être pris en étau
entre d'un côté la nécessité de
consulter de concerter avant la méthode
et de l'autre l'urgence d'aller vider
demander des transformations et comment
va être qu'est ce qui va se passer quand
les deux vont entrer en collision qu'est
ce qui va se passer si quand il va
lancer les cinq grands chantiers qui
repose sur la concertation les retraites
la réforme institutionnelle la fin de
vie la santé l'éducation
tout ça et conflits à des concertations
sous des formes différentes et variées
qu'est ce qui se passe si ça échoue il
va reprendre la main on va lui dire ah
oui mais vous nous avez donné une
feuille de route absolument impossible
on pouvait pas y arriver vous reprenez
la main vous n'avez pas changé face à la
difficulté rappelle la tribune de
laurent berger dans le monde 1 qui au
fond interpelle directement emmanuel
macron monsieur le président vous ne
pourrez pas faire relever ces défis tout
seul mais il faut que les autres
changent aussi c'est à dire les
syndicats le patronat il faut quand on
quand on concert qu'il faut être deux
donc il faut que les autres jouent le
jeu aussi jean daniel lévy quelles sont
les attentes des français on imagine que
c'est le pouvoir d'achat la première
urgence est ce que ces questions là au
fond de deux méthodes de gouvernance de
consultation de corps intermédiaires ça
leur parle 1 la question du pouvoir
d'achat vous avez raison c'est la
première des préoccupations et même au
sein de l'électorat d'emmanuel macron
c'est pas forcément cela qu'on aurait pu
s'attendre
après quand au monde aux français ce que
la question la méthode a une importance
ou pas la réponse est non mais on sent
que malgré tout on voit que malgré tout
même s'ils disent que non ça a des
effets inévitables et que au fur et à
mesure de la pression d'une méthode de
l'apprécier pardon une réforme
d'appréciation d'une mesure que au final
la question de comment ça s'est passé
quelles ont été les processus de
concertation qu'ils ont été les
processus de en gros délégation
d'opinion que ça a pu avoir des effets à
la dernière élection législative de la
sélection initiative moins de 50% des
électeurs sont déplacés au premier tour
moins de 40 3% au deuxième tour des
élections initiative est donc ça eu
comme un petit effet sur l'idée de se
dire que les députés nous représenter
véritablement été en capacité de pouvoir
parler au nom du peuple au nom des
préoccupations et qu' une des raisons
c'est pas la seule pour laquelle le
mouvement des gilets jaunes a pu se
développer c'est aussi parce qu'il n'y
avait pas forcément ces corps
intermédiaires qui arrivait à refléter
ce qu'était l'état de la situation la
population française dominique rousseau
alors c'est vrai que la question
institutionnelle c'est un peu un échec
du maquereau 1 on a l'impression à vous
lire mesdames que cette fois ci ça va
être vraiment tout en haut de la pile de
l'agenda leurs priorités qui va faire
cette réforme tout de suite d'abord
cette idée d'une commission
transpartisane avec des
constitutionnalistes peut être très
jeunes aveugles et avec des grands élus
avec toute une série de spécialistes ça
fait penser au comité balladur est ce
que c'est bon chemin est ce que c'est la
bonne méthode ça prend du temps aussi
est-ce que c'est pas risquer de
repousser à travers cette cette grande
commission alors évidemment en tant que
constitutionnalise c'est pour moi la
question des institutions est important
et fondamental dites-moi les
institutions que vous avez je vous
dirais la politique qui va sortir et on
le voit bien aujourd'hui si vous voulez
le la légitimité électorale ne suffit
plus pour entraîner l'adhésion
aussitôt élu le président la république
est contestée alors pas simplement une
macro mais c'est arrivé landes c'est
arrivé à sarkozy c'est arrivé à chirac
élue en 81 en mai 95 et qui se prend
l'intégrer providentiel
dans la rue et le problème de macron
mais vous lever
souligner c'est que je pense qu'il est
conscient enceinte dans son discours il
a une analyse correcte de la situation
ils voient bien qu'il ya un
affaiblissement de la confiance issu du
suffrage universel et qu'il faut
substituer à la légitimité électorale
une autre légitimité qui est la
légitimité sur le mode de mode de
production des lois le mot de
participation vous diriez d'associations
du citoyen à la décision je dirais que
lorsqu'il lorsqu'il a fait le grand
débat dans le quinquennat qui s'achève
lorsqu'il a fait la convention citoyenne
lorsqu'il dit il faut désormais avoir un
grand débat permanent il faut consulter
je pense qu'il a conscience que de les
citoyens aujourd'hui
demandent à être associés à la
production des politiques publiques
alors où ils le sont sur les ronds
points
bon pourquoi pas mais il faut qu'il le
soit ce serait plus quand même paisible
et démocratiques qu'ils le soient dans
des institutions d'où l'importance d'une
réforme des institutions pour que la
colère qui s'exprime dans la rue et qui
s'exprime sur les ronds-points qui est
une colère qui au départ pouvait rachat
mais qui très vite des bouchures lerrick
les institutions etc mais vous nous
dites ce soir au fond la défiance était
la crise démocratique est telle qu elle
mérite bien qu'on prenne un peu de temps
je pense que effectivement trouvé les
niveaux remède en une société de vitesse
c'est pas avec un claquement de doigts
qu'on va réformer la constitution qui
est quand même le pacte autour duquel
une société se met d'accord pour vivre
donc oui il faut une commission je pense
qu'il faut une commission à l'aveu des
louvel à balladur avec des citoyens
tirés au sort qui engage pendant deux
ans une un grand débat constituante dans
tout le temps de transit dans les
villages dans les quartiers dans les
zones dans les villes et au bout de ces
deux ans de dit mais ça c'est fait c'est
ce qui se fait au chili ça s'est fait en
y chante ça permet d'embarquer le pays
ça permet au pays
de se mettre sur pause et de 10 rebonds
où on en est qu'est ce qu'on fait où on
va quels sont les principes sur lesquels
on veut vivre désormais ça ça demande du
temps et la délibération n'est jamais du
temps perdu évidemment on peut t on peut
on peut décider comme poutine on peut
faire des u15 mais ce n'est pas ça qui
n'est pas comme ça qu'on fait marcher à
mon avis une société donc il faut du
temps et moi je suis pour une sèche
comment dire je serais favorable à une
grande délibération constituante
organisé de manière
impartiale et libération constituante ça
fait penser vous savez à quoi à la
constituante voilà réclamé par les
insoumis en tout cas dans la démarche
s'est signalé par écrit la constitution
si vous regardez je me veulent tout de
suite un référendum local pour conclure
ce débat mathilde de sirop cette
question de la méthode elle est
fondamentale on entend les corps
intermédiaires citoyens les
constitutionnalistes vous pensez vous
qui suivez l'elysée que ça va ça va
advenir même si ça prend du temps les
élections législatives l'avons ce jour
au scrutin majoritaire ça risque d'avoir
des surprises pour les citoyens qui
risque de ne pas retrouver au fond en
terme de représentation lors leur
bulletin de vote des présidentielles
tout ça fait 7 anticipé d'ailleurs parce
que selon les projections emmanuel
macron pourrait avoir encore une large
majorité ça veut dire quoi que la
majorité des français ça ne représentera
pas le rapport de force politique
majorité des français souhaitent une
cohabitation donc ça veut dire que s'il
se retrouve avec une assemblée largement
majoritaires à macron ils vont se dire
en fait je ne me sens pas représenté ce
risque-là il existe et autour d'
emmanuel macron on s'inquiète ce que
l'opposition qui ne pourra pas forcément
s'exprimer de à parts égales dans l'
assemblée s'exprime dans la rue à la
mesure de son poids politique et donc
c'est là c'est là où le chantier
institutionnel est majeur il s'est
engagé à réformer donc le mode de
scrutin pour la proportionnelle et là
aussi il n'a pas droit à l'erreur et
c'est le moment de lancer le chantier
moment de vérité politique merci
infiniment merci d'être venu sur ce
débat je vous propose de revenir
d'ailleurs au moment où on aura au fond
enfin cette nouvelle équipe et on pourra
analyser politiquement tous ses choix ou
va accueillir à présent notre grand
témoin il a été ministre de l'intérieur
de la défense de l'éducation il vient de
créer un nouveau mouvement politique en
soutien à emmanuel macron mais avec
quelques différences tout de même avec
le président à faire entendre dans le
débat public comment le socialiste qu'il
a été pendant des années regarde le
rapprochement du ps avec les insoumis en
a plein de questions à poser à jean
pierre chevènement
comme les skis ce sujet de marco pommier
regarder si on vous invite jean pierre
chevènement c'est parce qu'à 83 ans
l'animal politique que vous êtes suscite
toujours la curiosité vous auriez pu
être l'un de ses vétérans de la
politique qui dissertent sur le siècle
passé que nenni aujourd'hui encore
l'homme de gauche que vous êtes veut
peser dans le débat public cheveux se
nommant 20 derniers je serai un militant
au tour refondation républicaine car
allah et le projet jean pierre
chevènement faut-il encore vous
présentez député sénateur maire de
belfort pendant 20 ans ancien ministre
de la défense de l'intérieur et de
l'éducation nationale de vous nous
retenons aussi votre candidature à la
présidentielle de 2002 vous vouliez
faire turbuler le système des partis je
dirais simplement qu'il y à un mouvement
de confiance qui traduit simplement ce
que sow estime mes adversaires un
profond besoin de renouvellement dans le
pays qui ne veut ni d'un état rpr ni
d'un état ps la gauche et la droite
réunies un big bang dont vous avez rêvé
emmanuel macron lui l'a réalisé quinze
ans plus tard ce président qui n'avait
pas votre suffrage en 2017 mais que vous
avez soutenu en 2022 séduit par sa
tonalité souverainiste depuis la crise
sanitaire alors vous avez décidé de
soutenir l'action de ce président réélu
votre méthode lancer un nouveau
mouvement politique
refondations républicaine refondations
républicaine a pour but d'introduire
dans la majorité présidentielle
l'exigence républicaine
de faire en sorte qu' il y ait un lieu
de débat ouvert à tous à toutes les
sensibilités elles sont nombreuses au
sein de la majorité un nouveau courant
avec pour boussole la reconquête de
l'indépendance
industrielles énergétiques et agricoles
de la france une france que vous voulez
indépendante dans une europe autonome
sans oublier la lutte contre le hoki
semoule l'égalité des chances à l'école
car le fils d'instituteur que vous êtes
n'est jamais loin bref c'est un peu la
définition du chevènementisme 2.0 sur la
base de l'exigence républicaine il y à
vraiment en france quelque chose à faire
donc appel aux volontaires le message
est passé mais nous nous avons quand
même une petite question jean-pierre
chevènement refonder la république
est ce à dire qu'elle est à terre et
dans ces conditions qui l'a détruite
selon vous nous attendons vos réponses
bonsoir jean pierre chevènement bonsoir
et merci infiniment d'avoir accepté
notre invitation refonder la république
c'est un un nom de parti un titre
important refonder la république ça veut
dire aujourd'hui qu'elle ne tient plus
debout veut dire qu'elle est très malade
et on le voit avec cette confrontation
entre emmanuel macron et marine le pen
au deuxième tour c'est une démocratie
malade c'est ce qui la menacent le plus
la république la montée des extrêmes
écoute avoir ça dans une perspective
longue
lejard de gaulle avait voulu soustraire
la république au régime des partis mais
ceux ci se sont adaptés aux institutions
du général de gaulle à l'élection du
président au suffrage universel
parti d'epinay
j'étais pour quelque chose puis de
l'autre côté le rpr avec jacques chirac
mais ces partis ayant tourné le dos à
leurs principes fondateurs ont déçu et
suscité une vague de dégagements
toujours croissante par exemple en 93
les socialistes n'ont plus que 50
députés mais quatre ans après jacques
chirac rate sa dissolution et on
pourrait dire en 2002 il y à 13 millions
d'abstention mais ce sont des partis
traditionnels les fautifs
au fond emmanuel macho après cinq ans
après cinq ans de demande à il avait
promis aux lui aussi de réduire les
extrêmes si on additionne l efi
rassemblement national zemmour on est à
plus de 50 % ce n'est pas en partie son
à chaque je ne pense pas qu'on puisse
résonner des cette manière
emmanuel macron a dû faire face à des
événements totalement imprévue et qui ne
procédait pas lui même de lui-même de
centre l'action la sphère de vie le
jaune le coc vide
la guerre
russo ukrainienne donc il a fait face et
avec une certaine efficacité
je prends simplement l'épisode du coc
vide sur le plan sanitaire la pandémie a
été contenue avec un mot d'ordre clair
la vaccination sur le plan économique
avec le couac elle encore qui en coûte
et macron à inverser les priorités
disons que les critères de maastricht
que je vais combattu ont été suspendus
le la politique vous espérez adressé
pour longtemps j'imagine les critères de
maastricht faudrait peut-être les
supprimer maintenant il faut les revoir
profondément moins on parlera si vous
voulez mais
la banque centrale faisait une politique
austérité en europe les de la seule
mission qu'elle se donnait la lutte
contre l'inflation
or elle fait marcher la planche à
billets 4800 milliards d'euros
d'effet public rachetée par la banque
centrale ça ne se trouve pas sous le
sabot d'un cheval donc c'est cette
décision fondamentale pendant les crises
qui vous font vous soutenir aujourd'hui
le le président réélu vous l'avez
soutenu d'ailleurs avant avant qu'il ne
soit le pilier de cette revue de la
nature et que je gueule a soutenu en
2010 est au premier tour bien que j'ai
eu pour lui beaucoup de sympathie
naturellement mais je n'ai pas soutenu
parce qu'il y avait autour de lui des
gens qu'une sont pas de mon école c'est
clair donc j'ai simplement observé de
l'ue compte des inflexions qu'il a
apporté et c'est au vu de cette
évolution et des orientations qu'il a
donné notamment notre discours du 13
avril 2020 qui est un discours très
ferme qui donne comme axe de la
politique
la reconquête de souveraineté
industrielle technologique sanitaire
agricole de la france non tout cela m'a
amené à évoluer et je lui ai apporté en
janvier dernier mon soutien républicain
qui n'était pas un blanc-seing mais un
soutien à l'homme et aux orientations
politis tellement choisi la refondation
républicaine pas selon vous par la
réindustrialisation du pays c'est l'un
des axes de votre mouvement et votre
alliance avec emmanuel macron s'inscrit
dans cette priorité refaire des usines
en france refaire des ouvriers si je re
je pourrais dire refaire des emplois
industriels en france comment vous
expliquer au fond qu'on ait mis tant de
temps à comprendre qu'une france sans
usine n'était pas vivable je vous
rappelle que j'ai été ministre et
l'industrie en 1983 quand les choix
contradictoires ont été faites par
rapport au projet industrialiste de la
gauche à l'époque des choix ont été
faits qui m'ont amené à donner ma
démission et je pense que la
désindustrialisation de la france c'est
de cela que procède par exemple la crise
des gilet jaune l'accroissement des
inégalités donc manuel macron vous
trouvez qu'il a un bon bilan en la
matière la réindustrialisation on a vu
nos dépendances pendant la crise
sanitaire sur les masques avec la chine
sur des micro c'est quand même la
première fois depuis très longtemps que
des emplois industriels sont créés et
emmanuel macron a pris les décisions non
sans avoir parlé par exemple décision de
racheter les turbines arabe elle a
general electric à belfort rattrape hier
à belfort mais ça a été précédée comme
vous l'imaginez comme vous l'imaginez de
beaucoup de conversations avaient pesé
pour suivre dans le jeu c'est parce que
à partir du moment on faisait le choix
de recourir à nouveau à
l'électronucléaire parce que c'est la
sagesse c'est le bon sens tous ces gars
bien il fallait aussi s'approprier
serait approprié l'ensemble de la
filière électronucléaire on est à
l'heure comme la composition du
gouvernement on attend de savoir
évidemment il faudrait un grand
ministère de l'industrie qui soit
indépendant de bercy oui je comprends
que ces deux ministères doivent
travailler ensemble mais ce n'est pas le
même métier que d'être
soucieux d'abord des grands équilibres
de l'économie et puis d'autre part de
promouvoir des projets industriels à
long terme cet autre chose par
conséquent il ya place pour deux
ministères travailler en bonne entente
arnaud montebourg pourrait faire un bon
ministre de l'industrie je veux pas
descendre des
personnes alors emmanuel macron défend
une europe forte et souveraine
j'aimerais vous entendre sur cette
expression de la souveraineté européenne
il m'a semblé que vous dans votre
parcours vous défendiez plutôt une robe
certes forte mais il n'aura plus tôt des
nations est-ce que vos deux visions sur
l'europe sont compatibles mais vous
savez
il faut s'entendre sur l'emploi des mots
la souveraineté au sens du droit c'est
le peuple qui la détient et par
conséquent là où il y à un peuple il y à
une souveraineté
du peuple donc il ne peut pas y avoir de
souveraineté mais il peut y avoir une
autonomie stratégique comme l'a souligné
le président de la république
je ne vois pas très bien ce que ça veut
dire tant qu'il n'y a pas un peuple
européen et nous ne sommes pas demain la
veille de voir émerger un tel peuple
européen l'europe et diverses il faut
tenir compte des réalités partir des
faits pour aller à l'idéal mais en
restant quand même les sabots dans ancré
dans la terre et quelques petites
différences on les entend quand même
avec la vision de l'europe la vôtre et
emmanuel macron votre mouvement veut
aussi j'ai lu vos articles vos
interviews lutter contre le moc isme
vous pensez vraiment que woking est
l'une des principales menaces pour la
république aujourd'hui et c'est une dsp
de la déconstruction de l'idée de
république à la fois on sait par la
république de la nation du citoyen du
débat
politique argumentez et on donne dans
des idéologies pour faire simple
communautariste ou il en dit ariste ou
encore différentialiste qui met l'accent
sur ce qui nous divise et non pas sur ce
qui nous rapproche est ce que vous
trouvez que jean luc mélenchon héros
christ et vous savez quand on accepte
des réunions de racisées c'est à dire de
personnes du de la même couleur de peau
excluant les autres oui il y a une façon
là de recréer le racisme qui pourtant
est censé devoir être combattue donc
elle n'est pas républicain je pense
qu'il a des problèmes avec la république
prenez par exemple la 6ème république il
veut la 6ème république quand vous
regardez concrètement ce qu'il veut il
veut la ive république
malgré mobile nous a pas laissé de bons
souvenirs ces régimes d'impuissance le
discours d' de
l'instabilité au sein de stabilité et le
peuple français ne voulez plus vous avez
vu son affiche donc mélenchon premier
ministre pour les législatives élisez
moi premier ministre lance-t-il aux
françaises qu'il est gagnable
son tarif de pub là luc mélenchon se
révèle un excellent communicant mais la
politique ce n'est pas seulement de la
communication c'est quelque chose de
raisonnable regardons concrètement le
score qu'a fait jean luc mélenchon dans
le pays vannes 2 % c'est tout à fait
remarquable et maintenant compte du vote
utile il a mené sa campagne avec
beaucoup d'astuce et je suis loin de lui
enlever les qualités qui seront les
siennes mais je pense encore une fois
que jean luc mélenchon nous entraînerait
vers une ère d'instabilité
ne ferait pas l'unanimité
et comment vous regardez les discussions
en cours entre le parti socialiste vous
qui avait été socialiste pendant tant
d'années et les un saumon pour écouter
j'étais socialiste pendant 30 ans mais
j'ai quitté le parti socialiste depuis
30 ans donc j'ai un jugement assez
équilibré parti socialiste s'est défini
sous l'impulsion de françois mitterrand
comme un parti de gouvernement je me
souviens de françois mitterrand me
disant mais jean pierre
le pouvoir c'est la noblesse de la
politique je lui répondais certes mais
le pouvoir pour le pouvoir n'a pas de
sens et c'était une discussion de 1973
est lancée que les socialistes ne
cherche que des circonscriptions mais
sans sa maman choisi savent qu'ils
peuvent viser françois mitterrand est
vrai il a inscrit le parti socialiste
sur leurs hommes du pouvoir pendant
presque quarante ans jusqu'en 2017
maintenant c'est fini c'est terminé le
parti socialiste de par ses erreurs par
ses fautes aussi à créer les conditions
de son éviction
de l'ère du pouvoir
il est mort mais il déborde son fait et
pas du fait d' emmanuel macron ou de
jean pierre chevènement c'est trop
facile il faut bien que les socialistes
reviennent à leurs fondamentaux fasse
une analyse de la situation
économique de la situation mondiale et
explique aux français comment ils
peuvent se ressaisir de leur destin
c'est ce que leur propose emmanuel
macron je voudrais vous entendre jean
pierre chevènement pour terminer cet
entretien sur la guerre en ukraine déjà
comment vous vivez vous toutes ces
horreurs ces destructions c'est ces
exactions ces massacres au coeur de
l'europe de boer je crois que c'est la
russie qui envahit ukraine et pas
l'inversé il faut toujours le rappeler
donc je condamne cette invasion
naturellement je connais bien les
affaires russes et ukrainiennes et je
sais que tout ça vient de loin vient du
décret de dissolution de l'union
soviétique en 1991 quand trois
présidents le réussis alcine
cushman ou kravtchouk l'ukrainien je
skie vite chez le biélorusse se sont
entendus pour dire vrai c'est fini
chacun tourne le dos à l'autre et il
aurait fallu que nous mêmes nous gérions
le rapport avec la russie et le rapport
avec l'ukraine de manière équilibrée
sans vouloir faire de l'ukraine la
pointe avancée d'une agressivité contre
la russie que les russes ont reproché
notamment aux américains mais il faut
quand même à armer les ukrainiens
aujourd'hui à aujourd'hui c'est un autre
problème vous êtes favorable à trop du
crédit à cette aide surtout avoir comme
vision la paix le retour à la paix un
compromis permettant à la russie de
reconnaître l'ukraine comme une nation
libre indépendant à facile à un moment
où
il faut d'armes et plus souvent du
compromis auquel il faut arriver merci
le problème c'est pas de gagner la
guerre le problème c'est de gagner la
paix merci beaucoup merci jean pierre
chevènement vous rester avec moi je vais
vous soumettre à nos a franchi deux
chroniqueurs vont nous rejoindre dans un
instant pour leur parti pris ce soir
thomas legrand de france inter va faire
un peu de politique fiction il a
échafaudé le jour d'après la
cohabitation macro mélenchon et puis on
va accueillir aussi l'économiste au
collège de france philippe aghion pour
nous décrypter la stratégie économique
d' emmanuel macron bah écoutez je vous
propose de venir tout de suite installé
vous j'ai l'impression qu'il ya pas que
j'ai une gueule ça n'est pas bien grave
voilà bonsoir et bienvenue je suis ravi
de vous accueillir je suis sûr que jean
pierre chevènement sera très intéressé
par vos chroniques alors vous avez
terminé parce que c'est un peu politique
fiction mais c'est intéressant quand
même ce soir thomas on va commencer avec
vous philippe bonsoir soit vous allez
nous parler de la stratégie économique
d' emmanuel macron vous nous dites ce
soir au fond que la mère des réformes
c'est la réforme des retraites celle qui
n'a pas pu avoir lieu lors du précédent
quinquennat il faut la faire parce
qu'elle s'inscrit dans une stratégie
économique plus large c'est à dire comme
fait on doit rien du str et alizée notre
pays comme c'est à dire très bien il ya
un moment on doit accélérer la
transition énergétique et on doit
maîtriser nos finances publiques qui on
a une dette publique qui est important
notamment lcl a augmenté à cause du coc
vide d'accord et du quoi qu'il en coûte
hélas si ce cas puisque je regrette un
peu la proche draghi c'est à dire qu'est
ce qu'a fait draghi draghi il a utilisé
les fonds européens pour emprunter
davantage hors que l'italie est déjà
endetté pour investir dans la recherche
dans le digital dans la santé dans la
transition énergétique dans l'innovation
mais il ya eu du en même temps c'est à
dire qu'il est dit d'un côté je continue
la réforme de l'état pour être crédible
donc jeu réduit les dépenses récurrentes
et j'augmente investissements dans la
croissance et l'environnement eh bien
nous on doit faire pareil on doit
réduire les dépenses récurrentes
notamment celles liées au déficit de
notre système de retraite et réformer
l'état encore davantage quand nous
l'avons fait jusqu'à maintenant pour
faire les investissements qu'on veut
dans la récente réalisation par
l'innovation dans l'éducation pour faire
tous d'un bis mansle être crédible
réduire nos déficits des retraites
venant de vie s'il est d'accord là
dessus c'est évidemment heureux il faut
qu'on soit crédible ça va être un mas
triche modifié c'est à dire avant mettez
toutes les dépenses sur le même plan
maintenant l'idée de dire non il faut
regarder la composition de la dépense
publique et lutte et la gouvernance de
la dépense publique donc il ya certaines
dépenses récurrentes notamment celles
qui sont liées au déficit de notre
système de retraite il faut essayer de
réduire de contenir pour investir dans
la réindustrialisation dans l'innovation
dans l'éducation est scellé et c'est ça
le donc c'est d' approche différente
abandon avant le minimum de crédibilité
pour sur le côté retraites réforme de
l'état ces dépenses récurrentes pour
investir dans des pourquoi dépenser et
investir dans la croissance parce qu'en
investissant dans la croissance eh bien
vous augmentez votre solvabilité à long
terme évidemment vous réduisez à long
terme le ratio du pib sur le dieu de la
dette sur le pib elle est faisable ou
pas cette réforme des retraites on
comprend qu'il faut la faire selon vous
pour pouvoir réinvestir ensuite temps
des voix là dans la croissance verte
riche en emplois pour demain la méthode
draghi qui d'ailleurs à faire de la
bonne dépense c'est pourquoi le lan bien
là mais est ce qu'elle est faisable mais
écoutez tout dépend comment il faut
avoir une certaine attitude moi j'ai
jamais aimé les âge minimum 65 ans 64
ans l'a toujours dit que non moi je
pense qu'il faut plutôt de penser en
termes d'augmentation de la durée de
cotisation il faut augmenter la durée de
cotisation mais d'une manière juste qui
tiennent compte de la pénibilité qui
tiennent compte de l'espérance de vie de
la santé des individus et de l'âge donc
et donc ça prend en compte l'âge or on a
commencé des carrières longues quand
est-ce qu'on a commencé à travailler je
pense qu'il n'affronte l'oref a entendu
là-dessus mais il dit qu'il ne l'a pas
je crois qu'on va y arriver je crois
qu'en fait on y arrive ce concours est
comme ça et donc je crois que sur le
principe à ce qu'à deux autres manières
de réduire le déficit c'est de dire jeu
réduit les pensions
ou bien j'augmente le montant des
cotisations mais là quand vous faites ça
vous réduisez le pouvoir d'achat etc des
solutions régressive donc celle ci est
elle est progressive parce que là vous
préserver le pouvoir d'achat et en même
temps vous avez davantage d'actifs ça
c'est la vie c'est bon pour la
croissance c'est la réforme touraine en
fait l'essai touraine access et un
touraine améliorer et accélérer c'est de
ça qu'il s'agit en fait c'est
d'accélérer et de d'amplifier un peu
touraine voilà nous a pas du tout
présenté les choux et je sais pas ce
qu'on aurait dû battre et je pense qu'on
aurait dû gérer je l'avais dit à mes
amis à l'elysée tout je pense qu'on
aurait dû le faire comme ça et je pense
que ce principe doit être établie
augmentation de durée de cotisation et
après les modalités doivent être
négociées que les syndicats je crois que
c'est très important ça ça va être la
nouvelle manière de gouverner c'est fini
il faut plus dire je vous donne une
semaine et après j'ai agi par ordonnance
il faut arrêter avec ça il faut dire
voilà voilà les grands principes voilà
les objectifs ont embarqué les
internautes les corps intermédiaires
croyait alors j'ai juste au rythme
annuel macron
en verger et maître laurent berger dans
le coup complètement négocier pénibilité
espérance de vie carrières longues tout
ça doit se discuter avec les syndicats
et notamment avec la cfdt n'est pas
qu'elle un professeur au collège de
france qui est beau dit voilà comment il
faut s'y prendre merci merci bien moooh
philippe je vous ferai réagir mais je
voudrais aussi vous entendre tout de
suite thomas vous vous interrogez ce
soir sur au fond la question que tout le
monde se pose une cohabitation et tels
rivaux possibles eh bien non en fait moi
je ne pense pas les expériences de
cohabitation de 1986 avec françois
mitterrand président et jacques chirac
premier ministre 1993 avec le même
président edouard balladur premier
ministre 1990 est dans une configuration
inverse jacques chirac cette fois ci à
l'elysée et pour cinq ans lionel jospin
à matignon ces expériences ont été
plutôt apprécié par les français ça a
marché un les français ont aimé par
exemple
voir le couple chirac jospin
au sommet européen représentait la
france de façon comme ça un peu
syncrétiste on avait l'impression que
l'intérêt national et était bien
représentée et pourquoi ça ne serait
plus pareil bah tout simplement parce
que dans les cas de mitterrand chirac
balladur jospin les quatre personnalités
rpr et ps eh bien il avait qui étaient
donc premier ministre et président pour
les précédents de cohabitation il avait
les mêmes conceptions de la politique
étrangère de la défense est peu ou prou
de la construction européenne les
premiers ministres accepter que les
présidents dans le cadre de ce que l'on
appelle le fameux domaine réservé
comptes continuent d'avoir la main sur
la politique étrangère représente la
france dans les relations bio
multilatérale mais ça ne pourrait pas
être le cas demain si marine le pen ou
jean luc mélenchon sont à sont à
matignon en juin et tous les deux pour
son pour des projets par exemple de
désobéissance vis-à-vis des traités
européens
tous les deux sont défiants vis-à-vis de
l'otan chirac et mitterrand pouvait
laisser leur premier ministre de me
reposer mener leur politique du moment
qu'elle n'était pas encore la vie en
contradiction avec avec notre engagement
européen et l'alliance atlantique elle
là ça ne serait pas le cas imaginez
l'ukraine par exemple jean luc mélenchon
et contre la livraison d'armes à
l'ukraine tout comme marine le pen
qu'est ce qu'on ferait or selon
l'article 20 de la constitution c'est le
premier ministre détermine et conduit la
politique de la nation un même pour ce
qui est de la politique étrangère la
notion de domaine réservé n'est pas du
tout inscrits dans l'accueil s'est amusé
à une pratique instituée par général de
gaulle et que tous les tous ses
successeurs bien sur ce front on utilise
est né qui n'a jamais été remise en
cause donc par les premiers ministres ça
pourrait ne plus être le cas avec jean
luc mary nous avertissait la le pen on
irait vers des blocages alors en
1978 ont des législatives valéry giscard
d'estaing avait dit si la gauche gagne
j'irai à rambouillet où on n'imagine pas
trop quand même dans le château de
rambouillet il se paie se met en retrait
il ne pratiquerait pas la cohabitation
comme comme ça c'est passé plus tard on
n'imagine pas quand même emmanuel macron
aller à rambouillet on veut faire de la
politique fiction il peut dissoudre bon
ami à moi de réaction pour conclure vous
y croyez le point de vue de thomas
legrand moi je crois qu'un système
politique doit être souple et s'adapter
regarder ce qui se passe en allemagne
madame merkel avait prévu de s'allier
avec les verts finalement les verts sont
d'allier mais avec le spd ou me font des
compromis
des propos des familles il mais ça fait
six mois à faire des trois mois à faire
des compromis mais comprend un compromis
que font les biens sont d'abord avec de
m où ils vendent des armes lourdes 1 à
l'ukraine et ça s'est fait naturellement
la vie politique les verts les verts
sont souples la vie politique comporte
toujours des surprises des aléas en tous
les cas à s'adapter il faut faire
confiance au civisme au sens de l'état
des hommes politiques pour trouver les
compromis nécessaires en tout cas on en
est pas là on attend les législatives
parce que c'est bon hôtel les français
diront dans les urnes ce qu'ils
attendent de leur nouvelle majorité pop
pour le cohabitation le n'y croyais pas
de là n'est pas possible de
emmanuel macron avec eux
elle inchangée aujourd'hui jean-luc
mélenchon ou sajoo quoi ça marcherait
pas dû être très clair à moi si vous
êtes d'accord en fait j'ai des fourmis
de jory t présidentielle merci beaucoup
jean pierre chevènement d'être venu sur
le plateau des cp philippe aghion
immense merci thomas legrand pour rester
avec nous pour le documentaire de la
soirée sur la fermeture de fessenheim le
début de la fin du nucléaire point
d'interrogation signée jean charles
deniau très belle soirée sur lcp et à
demain demain c'est clément mairie
commana
[Musique]